did you know that two out of every three
guys will experience some form of male
pattern baldness by the time they're 35
i know it for me it was more like 25
because of course it was i wish keeps
have been around when i was younger
because advancements in science have
meant that there are now treatments that
can combat the symptoms of hair loss and
help you keep the hair that you have
look it is too late for me my hair is
not coming back but you didn't have to
be like me you could stop your hair loss
early thanks to keeps keeps off as
generic versions of the only two fda
approved drugs for treating hair loss so
you might be thinking oh boy simon this
is gonna be expensive because it's
medicine and i live in america well no
keep starts just 10
a month so how does it work well for one
thing there's no need to visit a
doctor's office just schedule a quick
online consult and a bit later a
discreet package is going to arrive at
your door and you can use keeps in the
privacy of your own home so if you've
noticed that you're losing your hair
that's one problem that's not going to
fix itself do something about it go to
keeps.com forward slash biographics or
click the link in the description below
and you'll receive 50 off your first
order and let's get into today's video
when the great war broke out governments
and generals expected it to be a short
conflict but due to a mixture of
arrogance and a lack of foresight
generals failed to realize that the
evolution in military tech could outpace
the development of military doctrine
strategy and tactics as a result many
fronts of the war turned into endless
massacres in which artillery and machine
gun crews made mincemeat of a poorly
trained infantry attacking with little
more than bayonets commanders responded
by ordering more futile attacks and if
soldiers did not obey they could risk
execution at the hands of their own
comrades it's no surprise then that many
such generals have been caricatured as
stubborn idiotic and despotic tyrants
prominently featured in such parodies
and memes is the commander-in-chief of
the italian armed forces general luigi
cadona in today's episode we will chart
his surprisingly peculiar life which
includes tales of kidnapping miracles
and we will assess his legacy of
incompetence to understand
if it was really deserved
luigi cantona was born on the 4th of
september 1850. his birthplace was
polynaza now northern italy back then
the country was yet to be unified and so
the newborn was a citizen of the kingdom
of piedmont sardinia luigi's father was
army officer raphael cadona he would
rise to the rank of general after
fighting in the crimean war and the wars
of italian independence in january 1857
luigi endured a terrifying adventure a
former steward of the family had been
fired for dishonesty and the man saw
revenge by kidnapping the six-year-old
boy the man sent a message to the
cardonas asking for ransom money raphael
was out of town so mrs cardona took
charge the formidable woman called the
police and then led a search party into
the nearby woods the kidnapper suddenly
got cold feet and fled to switzerland
leaving luigi in the care of three
peasants who walked him back home by
1860 piedmont had annex lombardi and
milan after the second war of italian
independence kaduna senior took the
occasion to immediately ship luigi to
milan to attend a military boarding
school was it to keep his son safe from
other bad experiences or to honor family
tradition well perhaps it was just to
get rid of an annoying brat as luigi's
school years are notable for his extreme
velvacity and mad pranks which
constantly landed him in detention the
boy was also noted for his intelligence
though and he graduated with good
results at the age of 15 he entered the
military academy in turin graduating
first in his class and receiving a
commission as a lieutenant in 1868. on
the 20th of september 1870 the young
luigi had his baptism of fire serving
under his father he participated in the
capture of rome until then part of the
independent papal state the kingdom of
italy had been unified since 1861 but
only now rome became its capital almost
all italian-speaking lands had been
liberated from foreign dominion and
influence thanks to alliances with
france and prussia but in the northeast
the surrounding regions trent and
trieste still belonged to the
austro-hungarian empire
italian policymakers and the military
still yearned to annex those lands but
in 1882 rome signed the triple alliance
with vienna and berlin this agreement
had been orchestrated by the german
chancellor otto von bismarck one of the
components of his system of alliances to
maintain stability in europe the deal
was advantageous enough for italy and
austria hungary but these uneasy allies
still bore a grudge against each other
in the meantime luigi had been steadily
climbing the ranks since becoming
captain in 1875 he took to publishing
essays and monographs displaying a knack
for teaching on advanced military
matters and in 1881 as assistant chief
of staff at the fifth army corps
cordonna was relocated to verona close
to the borders with austria-hungary on
this occasion he took the habit of
personally surveying peaks valleys
mountain passes and mule tracks seeking
the best positions to either attack the
austro-hungarians or set up the best
defenses he also started theorizing new
infantry tactics which were to be
appreciated by superiors after some
initial resistance codoner's doctrine
emphasized hard discipline but he also
stressed individual initiative which was
blasphemy at that time and place
subordinate officers and even ncos
needed to have a clear understanding of
the war's aims to guide their decisions
he was also a proponent of offensive
tactics employed rapidly and constantly
to wear out the enemy which may make
sense to a certain extent breech loading
artillery and machine guns had been in
use since the 1860s both weapons and
related tactics would give a clear
advantage to the defense this offensive
spirit was reinforced in 1892 when
codoner was appointed colonel of the
tenth regiment of the
bursiglia or fast-moving assault troops
while he was in charge he developed a
reputation as an inflexible
disciplinarian exacting harsh punishment
for the slightest offense gone were the
days of the prankster and the proponent
of autonomous thought
[Music]
as a senior officer cadorna now placed
the stress on unity of command and total
obedience he was still a proponent of
fast-moving attacks though as he trained
his regiment in quick enveloping tactics
in 1898 the colonel received his next
promotion and became major general in
charge of a brigade in the same year he
published a tactical manual which would
become the main one in use for the next
century the rise of codona was steady
and unstoppable but it hit a serious
roadblock in 1907 in that year he became
lieutenant general now commanding a
division in naples due to his reputation
as a military theorist general kodona
was shortlisted for promotion as chief
of the general staff but his stance on
unity of command did not sit well with
the cabinet the chief of staff was
expected to share command duties with
the king victor emmanuel iii but a stern
even arrogant cordona let it be known
that in no way would he co-lead with his
sovereign as a result he was sidelined
the job went to alberto poglio who was
much more friendlier to germany and
austro-hungary than his rival kaduna's
bitter pill was sweetened with yet
another rise to core commander in 1910.
in september of 1911 italy declared war
on the ottoman empire the eventual
victory for the italians would yield the
colony of libya and the annexation of
the dodhanese island the conflict is
also noteworthy for the first aerial
attack in which an italian recon pilot
threw hand grenades on an enemy position
due to his antagonistic relationship
with the government and especially with
prime minister gialitti he was denied
participation in the war codoner had to
content himself with participating in
large-scale war games during which he
perfectly executed a fighting retreat
all the while tensions were building up
in europe on the 28th of june 1914
serbian nationalist gavrilo princip
assassinated the austro-hungarian crown
prince franz ferdinand in sarajevo three
days later chief of staff general polio
the great supporter of the triple
alliance died suddenly of a heart attack
on the 27th of july king victor emmanuel
iii appointed luigi cardona as polio
successor
when austria-hungary declared war on
serbia there was no expectation for
italy to support its ally the triple
alliance only required for rome to
remain neutral kodona set about to
quickly reorganize and modernize the
army an arduous task as many resources
were swallowed up by anti-insurgency
operations in libya plus his orders for
a general mobilization were superseded
by the government as this would violate
neutrality nonetheless the general sat
down with his staff to plan for what was
inevitably to come a war against the
triple taunt and an invasion of france
by the alps well at least that's what
codoner thought was going to happen in
reality prime minister solandra and
foreign affairs minister sanio had been
leading secret negotiations with all
major european powers they had been
gradually shifting italy's alliance away
from the triple alliance and towards
britain and france the intention was to
enter the war against the central empire
and occasion to finally annex trent and
trieste the new friendship was
formalized by the treaty of london
signed in secret on april 26 1915. so
what did codorna know about these cloak
and dagger deals well absolutely nothing
when he was informed that he was to
attack the austro-hungarians he exploded
in a fit of rage but he set to work
nonetheless all those weeks spent
charting the borders would finally come
in handy on the 24th of may 1915 the
italian army crossed the border opening
yet another theater of senseless gore
and massacre hundreds of thousands of
italians austrians hungarians czechs
slovaks slovenians croatians bosnians
and poles endured cruel months on rocky
terrain paralyzed by cold and fear
driven insane by artillery their youths
assaulted by machine gun fire kadorna
amassed the bulk of his troops on a
front along the assanzo river also known
as the socha there the italians went
almost always on the offensive with rare
counter-attacks from their enemies in
total 12 major battles were fought on
the river from june 1915 to november
1917. the officer who had once proposed
innovative tactics and freedom of
initiative developed a strategy that
focused on one element only attack
attack and attack again blood muscle
guts and a few bits of metal assaulting
enemy trenches well defended and carved
into the stone of the alpine regions the
infantry was to engage in contact with
the enemy as much as possible until they
wore them down and broke through their
lines the staff's initial ambitious
objective was to march over the enemy
capital but godorna reasonably picked a
closer objective the port of trieste if
it fell vienna would soon be left with
little supplies
[Music]
on the australgarian front the defenders
were spurred on to resist all attacks
led by the inspirational leadership of
general borre evidence von buener the
lion of the asonzo on the italian side
infantrymen were motivated by the
draconian discipline imposed by kedorner
and put into practice by the inflexible
military police on one hand kodona
relied on sheer manpower as the chief
weapon on the other he neglected to look
after his men's needs breakdowns in
morale led to desertion and mutiny
commanders retaliated with even harsher
measures in a vicious cycle of
retribution and plummeting will to fight
as early as may 1915 the inflexible
general issued orders against
malingerers invoking the use of penal
law against these vile liars in june he
directed his iron fist towards officers
demanding that unit commanders up to the
regiment level should be immediately
sacked if deemed not up to the task in
september the strictest measures were
implemented against troops charged with
insubordination cowardice general cadona
wrote in a circular that soldiers trying
to surrender or retreat shall be reached
by the summary justice extracted by the
lead shot from the rear guard or from
the military police unless they haven't
already been gunned down by their
officer if surrendering soldiers were to
survive their own compatriots cordona
would ensure that they were tried in
absentia should they ever return from a
pow camp they would be executed these
measures were to be meted out on
individual soldiers initially but in
october codoner gave carp launch to
extend punishment to entire units at
once in a latter dispatch he suggested
that soldiers may be picked up at random
and sent before the firing squad things
went from bad to worse in november
codoner's staff authorized the use of
friendly artillery fire if a unit
refused to leave their trench and
attacked the enemy a statistical
exercise in 1925 quantified the
casualties caused by cadona's regime of
terror 4028 soldiers were sentenced to
death of which
2967 happened in absentia 750 men were
eventually killed by the firing squad in
addition to these sanctioned executions
a recent research piece found that some
further 300 soldiers have been shot
without trial by their officers or the
military police in the general's
antiquated world view this system of
ruthless retribution should have
tightened the cohesion and discipline of
the troops all it really did was destroy
their morale and resolve and it wouldn't
take long before the front line would
crumble
[Music]
on the 15th of may 1916 the
austro-hungarian empire launched one of
its rare attack operations the spring
offensive two thousand artillery pieces
unleashed a well-aimed barrage followed
by three hundred thousand troops pouring
in from the trent region into venetia
well trained by the german allies the
attack has exploited weak defensive
points to penetrate deep behind enemy
lines the initially stunned italians
suffered heavy losses but eventually
they managed to react cardona was not a
tactical genius but he knew one or two
things about logistics he made good use
of the local railway networks to
redeploy troops where most needed by
early june the austro-hungarians were
running out of supplies and the italians
pushed back at the same time the
russians launched their mighty brutal of
offensive on the eastern front units
were badly needed elsewhere and the
imperial operation lost momentum thus
far cordona had a well-deserved
reputation for stubbornly refusing
advice from peers and subordinates
however historian james f gench argues
that he did implement some tactical
innovations either developed locally or
imported from other fronts what cadorna
did fail to implement was an agile
communications system allowing for quick
dissemination of successful tactics
innovations imported from the western
front were especially slow to reach
codona and even slower to cascade down
his chain of command but on this
occasion the general had been hit on the
face with a new harsh lesson taught to
him by his enemies it was time for
payback and for once he wouldn't do it
with yet another relentless frontal
assault displaying again his logistical
skills the general amassed the brunt of
his armies and happy artillery to a
section of the front facing the town of
garizia on the 6th of august 1916
italian artillery pounded at the
austrian positions on mount zappatino
specialized infantry units went on the
attack carrying large white disks on
their backs a stratagem which allowed
artillery spotters to adjust their aim
another column captured the enemy
trenches approaching them via a maze of
galleries the mouth fell in 38 minutes
and the attacks continued with heavy
losses on both sides by the eighth
godorna had captured gorizia his first
major victory since the start of the war
within two weeks his army had made more
territorial gains than the previous 15
months of war but in a recurring great
war scenario the victorious offensive
was slowed down by a lack of supplies
exhaustion and heavy losses the front
line stalled again for yet another year
of fruitless head-on battles on the
zonzo even cordona had to admit that his
soldier's sanity was approaching
breaking point and that execution by
firing squad was not the only answer in
july of 1917 he circulated yet another
disciplinary order in which he
encouraged officers to look after the
morale and well-being of their troops as
he put it it is necessary to react
against the danger of the depression of
the soldier's human values but it may
have been too little too late yet
another enemy offensive was on the
horizon
in august of 1970 cadorna masterminded
another massive push the 11th battle on
the zonzo his orders were executed by
general luigi capello's second army who
reigned hell on the austro-hungarians
with more than 5 000 artillery pieces
the barrage was followed by intense
aerial activity and the first
operational use of the aditi special
units of trench raiders the result was a
tactical italian victory which worried
enough their enemies to call in support
from the german allies and so it was
that on the 24th of october 1917 german
and austro-hungarian troops launched the
most effective offensive on the alpine
front so far a shore barrage of
explosive grenades and gas was
immediately followed by infantry trained
in infiltration tactics a well-planned
well-executed attack which broke through
the lines defended by capello's second
army general cordoner had received some
intelligence on the oncoming attack and
had warned cappello about it but his
directives were unclear and he failed to
follow them up eventually the second
army had not properly strengthened its
defenses and it was overrun cordona was
also taken by surprise but relying on
his previous war game experience he
managed to save the entirety of the
third army and part of the second army
by organizing a fighting retreat the
rest of his forces though had been
beaten back severely by the 12th of
november the italians had been driven
back by almost 200 kilometers losing any
gains made during the war and even large
swaths of national territory they had
suffered forty thousand dead or wounded
three hundred thousand were missing in
action and a further three hundred
thousand had been made prisoners it was
a disaster which almost knocked italy
out of the war but as world war one has
taught us every offensive must stall
sooner or later cadorna managed to
reassemble his forces on a new narrower
front along the river piave from there
the italians managed to hold back the
invaders who had themselves suffered 50
000 casualties the fight had now moved
on to italian territory it wasn't any
longer a war of aggression against their
neighbors but rather a struggle to
defend the motherland morale skyrocketed
helped in no small measure by the prompt
arrival of french and british divisions
but after the route coudorna's own
morale had reached an all-time low so
much so but he contemplated suicide one
night alone in his office he was about
to raise a revolver to his head when a
mysterious young friar walked in he
carried a smell of roses and had
bleeding wounds on his hands and wrists
the two talked to length and the friar
calmly and serenely dissuaded the
general from taking his own life now
allow me to flash forward to 1920. the
war is over and luigi cadona travels to
a franciscan convent to meet a friar
rumored to work miracles upon seeing him
codoner exclaims he is the pr who
visited me to which the friar replies we
went through a rough night general
didn't we in 1917 friar was serving as
an army medic in naples so how could he
possibly have been in northern italy on
that night the clergyman later became
known to catholics worldwide as saint
pio of petrocena so had he saved
codona's life with a miracle of
bilocation i'll leave the matters of
faith to those that are qualified what
we know for sure is that immediately
after the defeat codoner's behavior was
perceived by his soldiers in public
opinion as far from saintly
in a widely circulated telegram to the
government he appeared to lay the blame
for the debacle on the troops on the
ground according to the dispatch the
defeat was the direct consequence of a
moral breakdown is terrible effects
weighing on the shoulders of those who
did not fell their responsibility as
soldiers and as men in fairness the
assessment had been co-authored by the
general and the ministry of war and it
singled out only certain elements of the
second army but the recently appointed
prime minister orlando already had a
proposal to dismiss cadona sitting on
his desk the defeated cappareto and his
perceived scapegoating of the troops was
the occasion orlando was waiting for the
stern and aggressive general did not
have many friends in the army nor in the
cabinet so orlando and the king removed
cadona from command by appointing him
italy's representative at the supreme
allied war council in this capacity the
former chief of staff served quite well
his advice was respected by allied
counterparts and he displayed a talent
for working in political and diplomatic
environments in the meanwhile orlando
appointed as new commander-in-chief the
general armando diaz who immediately set
out to improve the living conditions and
well-being of the troops with heightened
morale further allied support and the
introduction of the ardeti trench
trading corps the italians scored
decisive victories on the piabo river in
june and october of 1918. the australian
empire exhausted by a taxing war marred
by internal dissent politically
fragmented was already dissolving with
its constituent nations breaking away
and declaring independence on the 3rd of
november 1918 the once glorious empire
quit the fight and signed an armistice
in pedova
the war was over and so was codona's
career a formal inquiry had fixed the
blame of caporetto on codona's shoulders
and the general was forced into
retirement in 1919. his position was
briefly and partially reinstated by
benito mussolini who appointed him field
marshal in 1924. during that period
cordona also served as a senator but
never adhered to fascism by the time of
his death on the 21st of december 1928
he had fallen into relative obscurity
more than a hundred years after the end
of the war the debate is still ongoing
was luigi cardona the most incompetent
and cruel general of world war one whose
memory should be reviled and ridiculed
historian olga herwig lucidly lists all
of cadona's flaws he ignored terrain and
weather underestimated the importance of
supplies stressed the will to fight over
everything else devised strategies with
little relation to reality and insisted
on his own infallibility most
importantly he neglected the basic
requirements of his troops and fostered
the use of capital punishment and
summary executions herwig does point out
the same flaws were shared by his
opponents though on the other hand james
f gench highlighted that codoner was
logistically and strategically skilled
and while his tactics initially lacked
imagination he was more inclined to
learning than initially thought a trait
which yielded some important successes
furthermore codoner's conduct during the
route of caporetto was less disastrous
than the italian propaganda would lead
us to believe his conclusion is that
luigi cadona was neither an incompetent
fool nor a military genius he was just
another world war one general who
adapted too slowly and too late to a
world changing beyond recognition
so i really hope you enjoyed that video
if you did please do hit that thumbs up
button below don't forget to subscribe
and thank you for watching
[Music]